m
tous la vérité derrière allez allez
allez
pour la presse et votre pub du faux dur
mais on attend ça fait quinze ans que
t'as pas vu le médecin du travail mais
c'est pas possible ça mais il use in
polluent je pensais pas que on a le
droit de savoir et vous êtes journaliste
pour qui ces indépendante
répondez simplement évolué ça fait 29
ans que je bosse cercles ma fille si
présente vient d'y être embauché vous
pensez vraiment que si j'avais le
moindre doute d'un danger venant de chez
nous j'aurais laissé faire y'a quoi là
qui sort des tuyaux la cuisine à la
réunion deux jours vous avez dit qu'il y
avait un problème avec cuisine du mal à
avoir des infos précises mais c'est
aussi dérouillée c'est qu'il ya quelque
chose de pas clair
aujourd'hui les rejets sont traitées
différemment
aucun problème déversés dans des
carrières abandonnées 6 était clean il
n'en a pas toujours ce qu'il te regarde
pas mais je reste là je croise les bras
j'attends que vous savez tous ce soir
[Musique]
on va pas déclarer l'accident si on fait
rien ni personne ne fera rien un cancer
aussi rapide à 29 ans c'est pas normal
je suis pas lanceurs d'alertés accord
manipuler or cette pris moi je n'attends
qu'une chose pour notre commune york
pour avoir sans ce qu'on sait c'est
compliqué ce que tu vas donc je sais pas
je savais même pas qu'ils les autres
filles
[Musique]
c'est adrien mon frère mon beau frère
car moi au repas chez tes parents je
vais proposer de faire un petit discours
à notre mariage plus petit que ça ferait
plaisir et raison disque ou au plus tard
je l'avais pas vu venir celle là je
crois que quand je les dis ça ça l'a un
peu stressés ils pourront pas le faire
ce discours il avait appelé
[Musique]
je crois que pendant le dîner il
s'imaginait plein de trucs un peu
sordide heures
ici les imaginer qu'on allait mourir on
pas faire de discours c'est un peu idiot
puisque du coup à d'autres termes en bas
il aurait dû en faire un discours grave
problème viendrait bonsoir on va pas
faire long vous inquiétez pas on va
essayer en tout cas on est venu ici pour
vous parler du discours non je vais le
dire le discours scène un film sur l'or
techniquement c'est un livre mais là
c'est un film sur quelqu'un qui veut pas
faire de discours bah oui parce qu'il
aime pas les mariages car il aime pas
les poivrons non plus les concombres
histoire de quelques os qui attend un
texto sur feu et à la fin on croit qu'il
va y avoir un gâteau au yaourt et en
fait non
donc voilà le disco c'est un film c'est
une histoire d'amour et sur un
utilisateur un texto et puis veut pas
faire de discours ans qui n'aime pas les
pauvres à la faim
je suis ferme là vraiment on se marie
on va passer à des questions
personnelles mais rien de trop ainsi
vous verrez quelle est la fréquence de
vos rapports sexuels et le nombre moyen
de contact physique avec votre compagne
55 ans ça me paraît trop comme 50 6 1 6
ouais 4 5 6 vous allez tester une
molécule devra prendre un comprimé tous
les matins et dans la foulée vous
étreindre pendant une dizaine de
secondes nous étreindre c'est à dire
[Musique]
quelque chose pour cette première est
chimiquement sur m6 en a qui te rends
compte sur des bonnes raisons d'être
malheureux à spa dadkhah
à commencer par des genêts qui nous
permettent de mieux voir c'est pas
d'autres sentiments c'est le même mais
plus nette dans un couvent en largeur et
donc pour la suite du coup il ya pas de
suite à celui du traitement c'est fini
c'est peut t'arriver que nos patients en
fin de test ressentent une sorte
d'abandon tu arrêter les supports ne
reprenne le très pop
nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
savate on va pas aller cambrioler un
laboratoire
pourquoi mais normalement on n'a
peut-être pas besoin de ça
[Musique]
vous n'avez jamais travaillé avec des
détenus
c'est un petit peu c'étaient des jeunes
en difficulté qui avait fait du commun
cet appareil alors là je m'appelle
etienne je suis comédien ont offert des
sketches nos missions nous ont offert du
stand l'escale c'est pas trop mon truc
je fais du théâtre bizarre vous avez
jamais vus et concots un string star ne
serait pas avec nous tu réfléchis un peu
[Musique]
le plus grand auteur de théâtre du 20e
siècle
de quoi elle parle la pièce de domec
dans la merde j'espère de lendemains
meilleurs ça vous parle pas ça je sais
pas qui se retrouvent en situation
d'échec
je suis là pour les tirer vers le haut
vas-y seront au boulot
ça veut dire six mois de répétitions et
comment vous voulez que je justifie
samoa ils vont représenter tous les
autres ils vont devenir des exemples des
ambassadeurs
comment veux tu qu'ils y arrivent c'est
pas des acteurs dont moi si moi je vais
faire sa divine aphasiques ta mère sait
même pas ce que ça veut dire c'est quoi
ce bordel
cette répétition vous n'êtes pas dans un
théâtre ici vous êtes dans une prison
avec des délais un procès criminel
c'est papa comme ça moi je te parle
comme je veux je suis metteur en scène
ici moi je veux que les spectateurs ils
oublient d'où vous venez
je crois que mon envie de rien
le public est saisie du grand théâtre
vous allez faire une tournée
pas pour eux tu as fait ça c'est pour
toi et alors j'ai pas le droit d'exister
mois a laissé passer ça quand même
et au niveau ça vous l'emportez avec vos
personne n'en a voulu piquer
et fâcher
ah non j'ai pas fâché non mais je joue
là c'est mon texte abbas était bien
j'étais juge non
[Musique]
oui
temps frais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]